okay so in previous video which showed
you how to how to display our principal
components for samples on a chart we see
here clearly differentiated the re-air
symbols on the left along the PC one
axis the x axis and the t a triple
negative samples here on the right again
along x axis
except for this outlier on the x axis
now we're going to show you how to get
to principal components on your on your
gene this is the important part one if I
identify genes whose R represents or
imprints with opponents so we're going
to go to our principal components chart
here table here we're gonna ignore the
bottom part for now this shows our
principal components for each of our
samples I've already selected that but
we're going to copy this is again copy
the first two Prince components now
we're going to go over to here and I got
rid of already shown them that's I just
need to launch you how to do but already
done all of this work and we're gonna
paste special didn't work there sorry
let's go back here
copy and paste special and transpose and
it should do both them for some reason
it isn't let's see this works she's
special
all right it might just have to do one
at a time it's not working right now
if you do that
alright alright
well it should work with transposition
but of course as a record if it doesn't
want to and then we're gonna do with
that so now we've got them along the
other axis along columns principals for
four samples every right set up we got
pc-1 pc2 and so we're going to do a sum
product of these values for all the gene
expression values for that gene for all
the samples and then over here you see
along on the red the the principal
components scores for all those samples
for the first ones component and then
remember we're going to be what we're
all gonna do if these weren't all filled
out with a double click right there and
it'll autofill for us oh and make sure
you want this to not have dollar symbols
because you want auto fill and and fill
in for the other rows but the dollar
signs there will tell it don't change
the columns or rows here we want to keep
them and we will do the same thing for
your second principal component and then
we will copy those and put those over
into another one a separate sheet you're
still gonna have too many samples if you
try to do it you've got 17,000 genes so
we're gonna want to do this and then
we're going to select do a scatter chart
and he received clear differentiation
between between sets of genes here based
on the principal component and we see
principal Conant one providing most of
differentiation principle point two
doesn't really provide much at all we're
gonna choose this outlier out of the
possible interest in one and let's added
that data label and that gives us one of
the coordinates and so we're gonna copy
the coordinate go back here
and we're going to find its and should
point out that if you try to use the
full coordinate from the graph it won't
find it because it's cutting off your
significant digits or the principal
components you're gonna either increase
again for just delete a few of these and
we find this gene right here
and you want to collect the gene
expression values there select them copy
go back to here and do this paste
special again and transpose and I've
done the work here you're gonna make
separate columns for each of your groups
so make one for er one for your triple
negative and your single h ER loner gene
there or loner sample and then this
column here will be your sample names so
copy there select insert a chart a
column chart and voila here we have a
bar or column chart showing again clear
differentiation we have higher gene
expression a higher principle greater
principal component loadings for our er
genes and lower principal point loading
this for our TN and our Hg our genes and
this principal point one do the same
thing with principal component two but
guarantee this probably not gonna be
much difference and so that's how you do
the component Loudon's and how you try
to find genes and interpret the data and
in the text we are going to show you
what this gene is